should you wait for the m2 ipad pro or
just buy the current m1 ipad pro right
now apple could be working on an ipad
pro with a horizontal camera layout
that's going to feature both wireless
charging and reverse wireless charging
capabilities now what this points to is
apple adding mac safe magnets to the
back of the ipad pro the whole point of
that is that you could charge the ipad
pro through the back with wireless
charging while you have the main
thunderbolt 4 port available to connect
to different products and ssds if you're
bothered by certain things like the
camera layout on the m1 right here at
the top instead of on the side for
landscape use then maybe you should wait
or if you don't think the m1 chip is
powerful enough or if you would really
like the new redesign like the glass
back with wireless charging then you
should probably just hold off but in
reality i think the performance of the
m1 chip is already overkill for a lot of
people so don't think that it's going to
be a huge improvement